we were of course broadcasting live from
Las Vegas well live is not really the
right word but I was broadcasting from
Las Vegas last week at the mass towards
made perfect conference and people who
follow me on instagram at david pakman
saw a lot of what was happening behind
the scenes they're not the least of
which was the reality that in the Wynn
Hotel in the room that I was assigned I
had a front and center view the entire
week of Trump Tower in Las Vegas as you
can see here and like most of what is
associated with Trump it is ostentatious
and gaudy the reflective windows are
gold colored as you can see here Pat it
really protrudes in a way that is sort
of off-putting if you looked around
there's no other tall buildings in the
immediate vicinity of Trump Tower but
there it is just protruding out of the
ground in a very off-putting way and
that's what I had to look at every
morning when I woke up and every evening
when I went to bed
yeah the building is literally gilded
which means it looks nice on the outside
but I'm sure on the inside it's not as
nice
I was actually recently in lower
Manhattan and I did my best to avoid any
Trump buildings during my visit there
but yeah this is one that you can't
avoid that's the only thing in the
skyline unless I wanted to keep my
blinds shut the entire time and I don't
like to do that because you know you get
the the mountains in the background and
the entire thing I had to look at Trump
Tower every single day also as usual I
was criticized because I posted a
picture of me at I guess it's a the kids
these days I guess call it a nightclub
in my day we just called it a club okay
or maybe it's the opposite I have no
idea called excess at the Wynn Hotel and
the chainsmokers were I would say
playing that night but they don't really
play instruments I don't think so and
they look more EDM music yeah I guess
they heard when jiaying and that's so
funny I said hey I'm here for the
chainsmokers show and immediately people
start slamming me saying David I the
chainsmokers are lame and blah blah blah
you'll be pleased to know I didn't even
make it to the chainsmokers show because
we showed up at this place about 10 and
10
p.m. and once I got there it quickly
became apparent the chainsmokers weren't
coming on until about 1:30 in the
morning and I had to get up for a flight
in the morning so I just bailed and I
ended up in my hotel room before they
even came out did you know about their
two radio hits those are the only two
songs I know and those are the songs
that they have singers for as well yeah
I know I've heard of those yeah I mean I
listened to you know Sirius XM radio the
sort of top 40 channel or whatever
pathetic but I actually ended up leaving
before they came on but by the way these
clubs the obscenity of what these places
cost because we were part of the
conference we add like a comped table at
this club but we were asking around
apparently if you want a table
reservation at this nightclub on a on a
Friday night when we were there it's a
three thousand dollar minimum who he
doesn't know just just to get a table
and that includes you know the a $40
bottle of vodka which of course they
mark up there to like fifteen hundred
dollars or whatever it's absolutely
insane and we were just chatting like
who are all these people here like we're
here for free you know who who who's
here and people we were with were saying
you know there's bachelor parties
they'll save up for the year to show up
here and get a table and you might end
up at a pretty bad table actually not
all the tables even have a good view or
maybe you win a ton of money at the
casino and you want to blow it while
you're there because of course what
happens in Las Vegas stays in Las make s
it does and I guess I'm breaking that
rule because I'm telling you what
happened but in any case you can follow
me on instagram david pakman a lot going
on there